the Studebaker Avante was a chapter of
automotive history all to itself a 1963
Porsche had brought out its first 911
Lamborghini was developing its 350 GT
and Chevrolet had premiered its Corvette
Stingray the United States was turning
out cars as never before with Chevrolet
making some 10,000 a day the
long-standing wood now struggling
Studebaker corporation through its new
sports coupe a into the fray
the Avanti Studebaker had signed on a
big name in the automotive design world
French American industrial designer
Raymond Loewy had designed the coca-cola
bottle the Shell logo and the Lucky
Strike cigarettes package now he was
Studebakers last hope and tasked with
making the Avanti a success it was
radically different and needed
forward-looking with an innovative
chassis and powerful drivetrain it was
avant-garde on wheels
Huli Bell our president of the Swiss
Studebaker Club is a great admirer
pioneer designer Raymond Loewy and his
classy creations loi was aiming for a
lightweight streamlined car with low
fuel consumption his motto was ugliness
doesn't sound for coffee flakes dust
lunchbox and the avanti's case beauty is
truly in the eye of the beholder the
contours were unaccustomed especially
for the time but a closer look and a
good eye for detail reveals the real
beauty of the avanti's revolutionary
form single seats circular dials a stick
shift and simple interior were unusual
in American cars at the time it was more
the look and feel of a French or Italian
luxury car
the light and spacious interior seats
for adults comfortably another unusual
aspect for a 1960s coupe a via Von Teese
safety features included an integrated
roll bar the body was made of polyester
a cutting edge material that in 1963 was
still causing some problems in
production the polyester back then was
not very good quality explains fully the
lower it caused the paint to crack which
demanded more intensive maintenance the
engine is phenomenally powerful but even
with its disc brakes and fine
aerodynamics around fast curves the
Avanti shows its age and origins on
straight sections with a top speed of
190 km/h it more than lives up to its
name it set all manner of land speed
records for factory stock cars back in
the day
the avanti's engine is a 4.7 liter 240
horsepower v8 the optional supercharger
added nearly 100 horsepower more
in 1964 after turning out just 4,600
vehicles production was stopped two
years later
Studebaker was bust but the Avanti
outlived its maker
tune former dealers bought the Avanti
named production facilities and tooling
and hand-built replicas with Chevrolet
technology through the 1990s a tribute
to Raymond Louis timeless design